[Música]
se lo contamos aquí en France 24 buena
parte de la comunidad internacional
conmemoró el primer aniversario del
inicio de la invasión de Rusia a Ucrania
los medios internacionales analizamos
cómo está Ucrania en la actualidad como
está Ucrania el día de hoy lo que ha
representado la guerra para este país la
destrucción de las ciudades los
refugiados los desplazados y como desde
la perspectiva ucraniana la guerra
apunta a extenderse en el tiempo por eso
hoy en France 24 en su programa El
Debate vamos a dar la vuelta a la moneda
y vamos a ver la perspectiva rusa de la
situación este país ha recibido varios
paquetes de sanciones por parte de la
Unión Europea y de Estados Unidos muchos
de sus ciudadanos también han tenido que
dejar el país por no sentirse seguros
por no sentirse a gusto y también para
huir del reclutamiento para ese intento
que tiene el gobierno de reforzar las
fuerzas armadas de su país para hacer
frente al conflicto en la región del Don
Baz El Avance de las en terreno ha sido
lento de las tropas rusas en algunos
casos ha sido muy contundente y en otros
momentos a lo largo de este año han sido
menos acertados en torno a la estrategia
de Rusia lo que intentan hacer sus
avances o retrocesos son muy difíciles
de entender es muy poca la información
que llega desde Rusia nadie a ciencia
cierta sabe cuál va a ser el siguiente
paso que va a dar el ejército ruso o por
lo menos el gobierno que directriz va a
dar desde el kremlin Rusia liderada por
Vladimir Putin es impredecible hemos
estado retomando algunas frases del
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin para
tener tal vez como una guía para
entender la posición que está adoptando
este país se las presentamos a
continuación desde el inicio de las
tensiones en 2014 Rusia ha sido muy
clara en decir que ha llegado a este
escenario por sentirse amenazada ahí
citamos al presidente quiero repetir
esto fueron ellos refiriéndose a
Occidente
quienes desencadenaron la guerra y hemos
usado la fuerza y la estamos usando para
detenerla
el presidente ruso claramente ve la
posición y los movimientos de occidente
como una amenaza así lo da a entender
cuando dice occidente tiene un objetivo
destruir la antigua Unión soviética y
parte principal su parte principal
refiriéndose a la federación de Rusia
pero presidente Putin destruir la
antigua Unión soviética a ese país ya no
existe desde 1989 más o menos que empezó
a caer los gobiernos comunistas en
diferentes países o en diferentes
regiones del mundo occidente justamente
ahora está ayudando a una ex república
soviética que Rusia
Busca Como algunos de sus funcionarios
han dicho en el kremlin desaparecer del
mapa incluso han llegado a decir que
Ucrania Simplemente no debería existir
como nación occidente no está apostando
por su destrucción por la destrucción de
Ucrania en este caso Rusia mantiene muy
presente también La amenaza nuclear que
representa occidente para ellos citando
también al mandatario ruso en las
condiciones actuales cuando todos los
principales países de la otan han
declarado que su objetivo principal es
infligirnos una derrota estratégica para
que nuestra gente sufra como dicen Cómo
podemos ignorar sus capacidades
nucleares en estas condiciones
pero en reiteradas oportunidades Rusia
también ha hecho gala de su potencial
nuclear para hacernos sentir miedo para
dejar claro Cuál es la posición y
Mostrar su capacidad militar y que están
dispuestos a llegar hasta las últimas
consecuencias así lo dio a entender el
Primer Ministro ruso dimitriever quien
advirtió que de continuar Armando a
Ucrania llegaremos al Apocalipsis habrá
que olvidarse de la anterior vida
durante siglos así dijo
Ahora cuando ya se cumple un año de la
invasión y de la destrucción que hemos
visto a lo largo de todos estos meses en
Ucrania nos preguntamos Entonces qué es
lo que está buscando Rusia a esta altura
se entiende que quiere el presidente
Vladimir Putin Cómo está la situación al
interior de la federación al interior de
Rusia Qué piensan los ciudadanos que
piensan los sectores políticos los
empresarios los ciudadanos que han
tenido que salir del país que tanto
puede sostener Rusia esta guerra en la
que los triunfos se cuentan con los
dedos y el costo es gigantesco Rusia
después de un año de haber iniciado su
invasión a Ucrania es nuestro tema de
debate hoy en France 24 y para conversar
sobre este tema hemos invitado a María
Alejandra Santos ellas politóloga
ballester en seguridad y defensa
nacional es directora de la facultad de
la pontificia universidad javeriana
pontificia Universidad bolivariana en la
ciudad de bucaramanga también está con
nosotros Iván culichich él es
investigador del centro internacional de
defensa y seguridad él se encuentra en
la ciudad de tallin en Estonia y aquí en
el estudio de France 24 nos acompaña
Anastasia velosoba ella es investigadora
y profesora de literatura es
investigadora del instituto de cultura
Mundial de la Universidad de Moscú y
también es profesora de la Universidad
Nacional de Colombia los tres les doy la
bienvenida al programa Recuerden que
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
hacen parte de este debate pueden dejar
los comentarios y las preguntas a través
de las redes sociales en Twitter en
Facebook y en instagram nos encuentran
como
@frans24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f-24
todo junto mi cuenta personal arroba
santilogo no olviden y ya para terminar
que todos los contenidos también están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a María Alejandra en la ciudad de
bucaramanga en Colombia María Alejandra
Gracias por estar con nosotros y un año
después de haber iniciado esta invasión
o una operación militar especial como la
llaman desde Rusia qué balance hace
usted para el kremlin para Putin y para
Rusia
Buenas tardes Santiago Buenas tardes
para todos Bueno digamos que el balance
después de un año es un balance diría yo
que agridulce pues desde la perspectiva
para Rusia
Rusia Pues decidió lanzar la operación
militar especial y dentro este esta
operación pues buscaba una serie de
objetivos estratégicos que como el mismo
presidente vlaimer Putin ha determinado
y era realizar la desgasificación de
Ucrania y pues obviamente el objetivo a
corto plazo era Pues tomarse Ucrania
tomarse la Capital y pues realizar una
serie de decisiones políticas en torno a
pues lo que Rusia considera como o lo
que el plan geopolítico de Putin Pues
dentro de sus estrategia política
Pues yo creo que primero ellos habían
digamos que determinado ser una
operación corta una operación como la
operación Relámpago pero la resistencia
de Ucrania Pues digamos que un poco que
limitó ese balance a corto plazo y que
ha hecho que a un año pues ya veamos
unas implicaciones
económicas políticas y geopolíticas para
Rusia que pues seguramente
profundizaremos ahorita hago la misma
pregunta a Iván en la ciudad de tallin
en Estonia Iván Gracias por estar con
nosotros como siempre Un gusto saludarlo
y su análisis de este primer año de
invasión de Rusia a Ucrania pero desde
la perspectiva rusa qué se puede decir
el costo que ha sido para Rusia está
esta operación militar especial como la
llaman ellos
Hola qué tal es un gusto volver a hablar
con ustedes
diría que desde la perspectiva voy a
usar la tal llamada operación militar
especial la invasión y la guerra de
agresión que Rusia se ha desatado y está
llevando en conservando a cabo en contra
de Ucrania para Putin personalmente como
el líder de Rusia como
la guerra ha sido de hecho bastante
exitosa para él pues le ha permitido
consolidar su su poder le ha permitido
perseguir Y
en esencia de estar el gran parte de la
posición que quedaron al país se alarga
todos los medios independientes que
quedaban que en pocos pero quedaban
todavía y consolidar su régimen de una
manera que no hubiera sido posible sin
las leyes que pasó al inicio de esta
nueva invasión contra Ucrania
no hubiera sido posible para
crear nuevos poderes y extender su Su
autoridad de nuevas regiones podemos
profundizar en ciertos elementos Sí pero
diría que ese ante todo la perspectiva
general que la guerra para Putin si
hablamos de él como líder de este país
que ahora está llevando a cabo una
guerra de agresión para él la situación
ha sido favorable
y aquí en el estudio de France 24 saludo
por último pero no menos importante
Anastasia Gracias por estar con nosotros
Anastasia su perspectiva un año de
Invasión que le deja esto a Rusia
Antes que todo gracias por la invitación
Santiago gracias
Es un placer estar acá y poder compartir
lo que pienso sobre la situación Yo
estoy de acuerdo bastante de acuerdo con
Iván
se suele analizar la situación desde la
perspectiva internacional desde los
fines declarados por Putin pero yo
personalmente
veo que sus propósitos principales
estaban en el campo de la política
interior
buscaba consolidar su poder buscaba
aumentar
su apoyo claro a través de una serie de
propósitos realmente falsos
una serie de problemas económicos una
serie de problemas graves sociales
ofreciéndole a la población una una
nueva bandera un y un nuevo sentido sí
de pertinencia de ser parte de una
comunidad
y sensación de importancia y de grandeza
frente a una vida probablemente bastante
miserable de día a día desde esta
perspectiva Putin sí
logró sus propósitos logró consolidar su
poder y el poder de la oposición ya o
efímero en la en Rusia de hace de hace
un año ahora mismo si ahora mismo
prácticamente podemos decir que la
oposición no existe y que los rusos que
no están de acuerdo con las políticas
del gobierno están
deben callarse se sienten
y además viven una constante presión que
les viene desde afuera porque también
los rusos que salieron los rusos que se
quedan se crean una serie una ser
interminable de debates y todo eso
distrae la atención y la oposición no
logra consolidar sus esfuerzos para
combatir a su gran enemigo que es
realmente Anastasia continuó con usted
para hacer la ronda la inversa
tal vez lo que lo más representativo a
nivel internacional
sobre Rusia en este momento más allá de
la presión que ha habido de los
organismos internacionales son estas
sanciones económicas en el sector
financiero esto verdaderamente sí ha
afectado al país siempre se critica
estas sanciones porque van más enfocadas
en en apretar digamos a los ciudadanos
en vez de de apretar a los a los
gobiernos de turno que se siente allá en
Rusia sobre este tema
yo llevo tiempo fuera del país también
por razones políticas pero mi familia si
tengo familia en Rusia y gran red de
amigos he conocidos y yo podría decir
que en este momento todavía no se siente
mucho el efecto de las sanciones cuando
empezó la guerra los expertos y también
las personas si estaban esperando un
efecto inmediato y hubo un momento de
pánico cuando efectivamente
desaparecieron algunas cosas hubo
desabastecimiento un poquito como pasó
con la pandemia
recuerdo que no sé por por un momento
desaparecía pero no porque realmente
hacen falta sino porque las personas se
asustaron y empezaron a hacer
provisiones para varios años varios años
de guerra ahora mismo se siente la
inflación
las personas que tenían ahorros que
tenían
ciertos recursos por
esto tiene se sienten afectados porque
por ejemplo no pueden sacar
su plata del país es difícil vender por
no sé la parte un apartamento porque
muchas personas se han ido sí el mercado
vive una toda muchas muchas turbulencias
sin embargo sin embargo
la gente normal todavía no siente tanto
estos estos efectos está la inflación
pero los supermercados están están
llenos de cosas y sí la vida transcurre
con normalidad que es un poquito
Tal vez es triste porque si el efecto
logrado no no no no no se dio Claro sí
lo que se buscaba no se dio claro y hay
que decir que la inflación pues es un
efecto transversal para todos los países
del Mundo a raíz de la recuperación
económica por por la pandemia de Kobe 19
le doy la palabra Iván Iván su análisis
sobre un año de sanciones recientemente
también Estados Unidos impuso un décimo
paquete de sanciones a Rusia y también
de una manera Express lo hizo la Unión
Europea como acto seguido qué balance se
hace de estas sanciones
no estoy de acuerdo con Anastasia que en
efecto
las sanciones han logrado no han logrado
verdaderamente
transformar la economía rusa en una
manera que
ejerza presión contra el régimen de
Putin
han aumentado la inflación quizás han
hecho más difícil acceder a ciertos
bienes de importación
Moscú Ha logrado responder a esto
creando redes de importaciones
secundarias
de
ajustes a su economía de manera que
un aislamiento económico no no perjudica
los sectores clave de la economía como
el sector energético el sector de
producción de armas Sí
más
la venta de energía de productos
energéticos
[Música]
continúa con una política de descuentos
de modo que todo esto
hace más difícil y más compleja
los resultados de la política de
Internacionales sanciones contra Rusia
habría que había que ver cuáles son los
huecos digamos en esta política que
Rusia lo que explotar para
consolidar su política de adaptación
económica pero por el momento la
trayectoria según mi perspectiva es que
use va a seguir adaptándose economía
para que pueda funcionar en un entorno
de sanciones
maneras semejante como Irán o colgar
María Alejandra García Ramos esta ronda
con usted en la ciudad de bucaramanga su
perspectiva de las sanciones está
impuestas por Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea
Bueno pues las sanciones tienen un
objeto es a largo plazo evidentemente
pues como la guerra se ha extendido en
el tiempo lo que se ha buscado es
afectar Esa condición esa capacidad
económica y financiera de Rusia para
financiar la guerra y creo que Rusia y
como ya lo han documentado varios
analistas
te ha venido o se vino preparando desde
el año 2014 con las sanciones que se
hicieron en su momento a fortalecer su
economía y por eso también este año de
de esta operación militar especial
buscaron unos nuevos socios comerciales
como China la India y Turquía en el cual
Pues están por ejemplo las exportaciones
de petróleo fueron del setenta por
ciento entonces Rusia obviamente Dentro
de este panorama económico buscó otros
aliados comerciales para cumplir esta
necesidad y pues que evidentemente pues
no tenido el impacto económico que quiso
en su momento Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea y dentro pues de todas estas
estrategias de política exterior que
tienen los países y las organizaciones
multilaterales pues todas esas sanciones
tienen dan un efecto a largo plazo María
Alejandra un año después de haber
empezado esta invasión y de todo lo que
ha transcurrido a lo largo de estos
meses en Ucrania y la atención
internacional y la repercusión que ha
tenido este conflicto a nivel
internacional porque no es una guerra
mundial pero si es una guerra que ha
llegado a tener una escala global debido
al impacto que ha tenido usted puede
entender Qué es lo que está buscando
Rusia y que busca el presidente Putin
porque hay un discurso que no sé si
usted de pronto lo encuentra también
como contradictorio que quieren sacar a
un supuesto gobierno nazi de Ucrania
pero también quieren forzar un nuevo
orden internacional Cuál es la verdadera
estrategia de ellos para estar en
Ucrania qué es lo que buscan
Pues el presidente Vladimir Putin desde
que pues ha venido pues gobernando Rusia
y dentro de los documentos de seguridad
nacional y política exterior que uno
puede datar casi desde el año 2000 era
Buscar esa ese ese posicionamiento
internacional de Rusia de algo que se
conoce y que de pronto acá los los
colegas sabrán del proceso de
remperialización que Rusia pues ha
tenido y que busca dentro de su
pensamiento geopolítico entonces creo
que esta apuesta estratégica de Rusia en
este momento en esta coyuntura especial
es precisamente Para volver a posicionar
a Rusia dentro del escenario
internacional recuperar la influencia
internacional que que tuvo en su momento
Durante la Guerra Fría y creo que eso es
como el objetivo Pues a largo plazo
Y eso es lo que uno entiende desde el
lado de este lado del Atlántico
Anastasia cruzamos desde desde
bucaramanga hasta acá para los rusos
para la sociedad rusa es claro lo que
está buscando el gobierno es Claro ese
sentimiento que
explicaba María Alejandra de una
reimperialización del país es difícil
contestar
esta pregunta por qué primero no existe
una sola sociedad rusa Aunque desde
desde afuera parece que todos los rusos
juntos están apoyando al Gran líder
la realidad no es así también esta
impresión se da el hecho que desde por
ejemplo en América Latina Rusia Rusia es
un fenómeno desconocido que es Rusia no
se sabe no se sabe no se conocen las
regiones no se conoce la historia no se
conocen las relaciones que ha tenido
Rusia
Moscú con gif etcétera un
desconocimiento muy grande que produce
toda una serie de errores de percepción
Rusia es una sociedad muy compleja y no
se puede decir que
tengan todos las la misma visión de de
las políticas de las políticas de Putin
por supuesto hay una gran parte de la
población que Nosotros simplificando
llamamos televidentes los que siguen los
canales de televisión del gobierno que
básicamente todos los todos los medios
de comunicación hoy en día pertenecen se
transmiten la misma la misma visión
ellos van a probablemente Reproducir
algunos elementos de este discurso sin
embargo hablar de un entendimiento real
de de esta propuesta Me parece que que
no es posible porque esta propuesta es
contradictoria sí es una nosotros vemos
que lo que Putin declara en un momento
en otro
no crea una una propuesta una política
coherente por eso sí podemos decir
entonces hay personas que dicen okay Lo
que nos dice puten es esto y pueden
repetirlo hay otras partes de la
población entre ellos de hecho los de
derecha más radicales que puten que ven
esta incoherencia y se quejan
constantemente de que no les dan unas
razones claras una explicación Clara de
toda esta política y de otro lado por
supuesto está toda la parte
de la oposición que
considera absolutamente no incoherente
este discurso muchos Creo yo afirmaría
que gran parte de de esta parte de gran
parte de esta sociedad crítica
ve el conflicto en Ucrania como una
consecuencia de la de las políticas
internas de Putin y lo analiza desde
esta perspectiva es decir todo lo
geopolítico todos todo este discurso
simplemente es irrelevante para la gran
parte de los expertos rusos que están en
oposición a las políticas del gobierno
claro y una una muestra Clara de que no
todos los rusos están de acuerdo con
esta esta operación militar especial y
lo que ha venido de parte del a lo largo
de estos 12 meses es la cantidad de
rusos que se han ido del país en los
últimos meses que ya lo vamos a tocar
más adelante porque eso da en cierta
forma un indicio de opiniones diferentes
usted hablaba de un debate que hay
dentro de incluso de las mismas familias
y hay una sociedad en cierta forma
polarizada en cuanto a este a este tema
lo dejamos sobre la mesa Anastasia Ya lo
vamos a conversar Quiero preguntarle a
Iván sobre sobre la fuerza que tiene el
presidente Putin en este momento
al interior de la federación se sigue
manteniendo como un Más allá del
discurso y más allá de quienes compren o
no sus ideas él se sigue mostrando como
un hombre fuerte dentro de los rusos
dentro de los diferentes sectores y
sigue siendo ese punto de cohesión de un
país que como dice Anastasia tiene una
sociedad muy compleja
porque es muy diversa sigue siendo él
ese punto de Unión
el aspecto geopolítico es cierto la
política interna y la dinámica interna
en Rusia
anima esta purpurina realizar esta carga
pero también hay que tomar en cuenta que
la política la política exterior hoy en
día también está empujada por una
ideología Imperial como ya se ha
mencionado pero también una ideología
que
se contrapone que busca
se compone al orden mundial actual que
se basa en la idea que la democracia es
el único sistema político legítimo y que
busca legitimar a la autocracia como una
forma política legítima Bueno eso es
acerca de esta idea sobre geopolítica
que quise mencionar ahora sobre Putin
pienso en pocas palabras que sí que Su
autoridad a pesar del caos que está que
la guerra de Gran escala que desató
ha creado
no hemos buscado y hemos intentado
seguir si emergen algunas fisuras dentro
de la élite en el kremlin o en torno al
kreming podemos hablar de
podemos hablar de
todos los personajes que ocasionan y que
se dice pueden crear una autoridad
paralela o incluso
un desafío a la autoridad de Putin pero
de hecho
en mi perspectiva Putin se mantiene
mantiene
No solamente la autoridad pero todos los
instrumentos para mantener el poder en
el país
para Alejandra pasó a preguntarle por un
tema destacado y es justamente el
discurso lo que hemos visto a lo largo
de este año tanto desde la ucraniano
como desde el lado ruso pero ahora nos
vamos a enfocar en el lado ruso
Anastasia nos decía la capacidad de los
medios rusos están completamente
cooptados por el gobierno todos
pertenecen a al gobierno de turno allí
en la federación hay censura hay un
discurso repetitivo que habla de un
supuesto gobierno nazi gobernando
Ucrania Habla lo dijo el presidente
Putin Hace unos días en su discurso a la
unión por ejemplo que la pedofilia
estaba completamente normalizada en el
mundo occidental
que se habla de esta operación militar
especial en vez de una invasión el
manejo del discurso ha sido clave a lo
largo de estos años a lo largo de estos
meses y qué papel juega el discurso
tener control de los medios de
comunicación y la censura
Bueno creo que ahí el discurso que ha
manejado el gobierno de Vladimir Putin
ha sido fundamental un poco para generar
como toda esa línea discursiva de
justificación de llevar a cabo la la
operación militar especial y radica en
torno a las razones o la justificación
que llevaron a la decisión política de
pues iniciar toda la operación y creo
que cuando un gobierno en este caso
tiene acceso a los medios de
comunicación puede controlar los flujos
de información y demás pues eso lo pone
dentro de un contexto o discursivo
digamos que bastante relevante porque no
hay otra contraposición que o otro medio
de comunicación a los cuales se puede
acceder y tener otra información algo
que que se mencionábamos en estos días a
raíz del aniversario era que este
conflicto ha potencializado los códigos
abiertos es decir que las personas en
Ucrania puedan dar información
real sobre lo que pasa y pues en Rusia
Hay un problema y es que como el
gobierno Pues tiene un control de los
medios de comunicación Esto hace que
todo el discurso político el mensaje
político este en torno a favor de la
operación y en términos de control de la
opinión pública pues eso es bastante
relevante porque y nosotros como los
politólogos lo llamamos pues la
propaganda política para justificar una
guerra es un elemento esencial y ahorita
digamos muchos analistas hablan que esta
este conflicto entre Rusia y Ucrania se
puede llegar a denominar un picto de
quinta generación porque pues es la que
explica o determina como el control de
la información y esos procesos
cognitivos de como el ciudadano
entiende la guerra pues Rusia ha sido
bastante digamos
estratégica en saber cómo controlar los
flujos de información pues tanto
internos como también externos Por eso
existen
y todos estos medios de comunicación
rusos claro María Alejandra ya estoy que
Añadir las noticias falsas y también hay
que Añadir que aquí en el mundo
occidental en Europa y en América Dónde
estamos también hemos sido presas de la
censura aquí no podemos ver medios rusos
no tenemos acceso a información así sea
oficial así sea parte de esa propaganda
del kremlin a la que también podríamos
tener acceso justamente para analizarla
y entender que lo que está detrás de ese
mensaje de propaganda del kremlin
entendiendo Cuál es la función de ese
mensaje emitido por el gobierno ruso no
todo el mundo lo entiende así la gente
lo traga entero y ahí es donde entra
Pues el conflicto en cuanto a la
información todo hay que tomarlo con
pinzas en cuanto a este conflicto y van
continúo con usted para hacer la ronda
la inversa y Anastasia para hablar del
tema de la de la salida de cientos de
ciudadanos rusos usted ustedes están
Estonia está en tallin Supongo que allí
han llegado muchísimos ciudadanos rusos
escapando del reclutamiento obligatorio
para unirse al ejército o también pues
porque quieren irse del país porque la
situación Ya no les resulta cómoda y
deciden dejar la federación esto habla
de también un poco de malestar social
que hay frente al gobierno pero pero
poco nada hacen los ciudadanos para
mostrar ese descontento frente a las
políticas de Putin solo irse del país
Bueno sí en Estonia particularmente la
situación ha sido que
no se permite la entrada al país a
partir de una de la visa turística que
es la con la cual
muchos han tenido bueno Muchos
ciudadanos
anterior la intención de salir para
evadir la la el reclutamiento a la
guerra por cualquier causas que se
pongan a ese reclutamiento
la causa por el cual la extraña no
permite la salida la entrada de
ciudadanos
con vista turística es porque por fin
Estonia es un país limítrofe
Rusia ha usado la población rusas en
losófanas para ser más exacto pero
poblaciones que hablan el bioma de uso
Como un pretexto para llevar a cabo
intervenciones militares en Ucrania en
2014 eso fue parte de la justificación
para el inicio de la invasión
perspectiva en Estonia ha sido diferente
no obstante claramente Estonia ha dado
asilo a muchos miembros en la posición
rusa y por lo tanto la perspectiva en
Estonia es
digamos un tanto diferente que la que
podemos encontrar en kazajistán o en
Jauja que han sido dos países que han
recibido
muchos muchos usos que han salido del
país en los últimos meses sí Muchos de
ellos han llegado a kazajistán a Georgia
a Georgia perdón O a Armenia también en
el cáucaso por este lado Anastasia esta
salida de los ciudadanos rusos también
culturalmente pues esto esto dice mucho
de también de la integración de estos
países con la federación que lo ven
fácil simplemente cruzar la frontera y
e irse pero también dice mucho de esa
imposibilidad de poder expresar su
inconformidad con el gobierno
Sí exactamente en realidad para muchos
rusos No ha sido fácil salir del país
Porque muchos países europeos cerraron
sus puertas Entonces
no no hay en este momento muchas
opciones Entonces sí existen estos
países
cercanos y tradicionalmente
culturalmente también cercanos a Rusia
también por el pasado soviético y Y
antes del imperio ruso pero también
bastantes bastantes rusos llegaron por
ejemplo Argentina sí que Argentina
es un país que tiene políticas bastante
favorables para para la migración
Yo podría decir que
esta salida afectó sobre todo a la clase
más a la parte más globalizada más
educada
más
occidentales
de la sociedad rusa
digamos entre los jóvenes profesores
universitarios jóvenes
[Música]
investigadores o personas que trabajan
en sectores como
Inteligencia artificial
tecnología muchos muchos salieron
salieron del país
Por qué Porque en Rusia realmente no se
pueden expresar y además se ven
amenazados sí sobre todo los hombres
jóvenes se ven directamente a amenazados
por la movilización del reclutamiento
forzado
y muchos de hecho muchos salieron y
muchos salieron incluso antes
simplemente por no poder estar por no
poder seguir en esta atmósfera
imperialista totalitaria militarista
etcétera etcétera
una parte de la población también se
refugió en lo que Nosotros llamamos
tradicionalmente
inmigración interna es decir que uno se
deja de pronunciar habla de cosas
políticas solo con las personas más
cercanas con las cuales con seguridad
comparte la misma visión y la sensación
general es yo la llevaría como depresión
generalizada
no se sabe que esperar
sensación de ser culpable de ser
culpable de ser involucrado pero no
saber qué hacer
Esto es lo que como yo podría describir
esta esta salida Sí un poco de la
incertidumbre qué va a pasar con la
guerra y el rumbo del país la
incertidumbre digamos preocupación por
su futuro Pero también es una cosa más
espiritual existencial yo diría Porque
muchos rusos y yo también nos vemos
todo lo que somos está cuestionado todas
estos grandes mitos que antes también
claramente digamos con ojos escépticos o
en día si deben ser deconstruidos y todo
lo que somos de nuestra percepción de
nosotros mismos debe cambiar y eso no es
un proceso fácil y no es un proceso de
la noche a la mañana y eso tomará
muchísimo tiempo cambiar esa esa
perspectiva interna me quedan ya pocos
segundos para finalizar el programa yo
les Quiero agradecer a ustedes no
alcanzo a hacerlos con las conclusiones
del programa porque pues simplemente ya
se acaba el tiempo pero le Quiero
agradecer Anastasia Sia María Alejandra
y ahí van a haber estado con nosotros
habernos puesto en perspectiva la
perspectiva rusa de este conflicto de
esta invasión les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros es todo por el
momento aquí en el programa la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera les agradezco mucho haber estado
con nosotros sigan con franz24
[Música]